what if someone feels like they're not
ready to pursue the film business look I
mean you hopefully know yourself but
anybody else I mean if you haven't had
enough
if you haven't studied it enough if you
haven't it depends on what you want to
do if you're if you're a producer work
for another producer become an assistant
right if you if you want to do
development for example if you want to
be an actor well you need to take
probably a lot of classes and and be
confident that you can you know hit the
marks do this do that or whatever you
need to you need to get in a space where
you're comfortable and confident enough
to be able to to do whatever job it is
you want to do in this industry and I
think a lot of that comes from doing and
learning I mean you know you may need to
work as a PA or whatever like look
lurking if you want to learn all the
jobs in production working in a PA is a
great job you don't get paid anything
but you get to see and learn a lot of
things and if you're on certain
Productions you know if you take
interest in certain things people may
take interest in you and you know you
may become oh wow I'm interested in
sound well come here look learn how this
works and they'll help you out and then
hey I need an assistant next time why
don't you you know you'll be the boom
guy and then you go and you do that you
can wear a lot of different hats being
in PA and you can learn and kind of
figure out maybe what you know who your
tribe is if that makes sense even extra
work and you get fed and you get paid
yeah you want to see how like how it
works right understand it I mean it's
there's there's lots of ways to learn
and get paid a little bit at least you
know
how does a filmmaker know they have
something to offer a story worth telling
it's a great great question the um
I always like to
say if it's original that's one thing
um if it's some or it's something you
haven't seen in a long time that's
another thing too
um you know I think that you learn of
it's original by watching by like you
know learning and reading and watching a
lot of different movies to understand
the landscape or the genre even let's
say for example of what you're trying to
like do
um I uh I think that
if it's
if it's not just watching the films it's
reading it's understanding story it's
understanding what other stories are out
there like this is there a book that's
exactly like this what I'm trying to
write right here is there another movie
that like from here to Sundance that was
you know about you know a guy living in
iron lung or something like this
whatever you're trying to do there might
be something similar to it so check
beforehand make sure it's somewhat
original and then ask yourself there's
an audience for this like should going
back should this movie be made is there
an audience for this who's going to
watch this film who's going to pay to
see this film right because people want
their money back at the end of the day
you can only you can only do so much
with investors you get one chance with
certain investors you never make that
money back yeah you might not get a
second chance
what if the story is about the writer
director producer
and it's their story and they're just
convinced everyone wants to see it they
may people may want to see that but is
there a delusion sometimes when people
have their own story I think there's
absolutely a delusion
um I think you know unfortunately uh
people are very you know they're very um
what's the word
um
ah
they they really do believe that their
story is the most important Story Ever
Told probably right and it's the most
interesting story ever told and
sometimes it's not sometimes it's just
not I think that you have to have other
people that um you know that's what
producers do producers will read your
script and tell you oh listen I think
that there is something here like so
there's other people's opinions that
sort of matter I don't think it's just
in a vacuum a writer director coming up
with something that's just going to be
brilliant I think there's always people
that are going to help that project
along and actually even tell you look I
I'm encyclopedic with my knowledge of
horror for example like I can tell you
that movie I've seen it 10 years ago and
it wasn't done very well then so this
movie may actually work or this movie
there's a movie that came out just like
it like last year and it was done really
well you know I had a couple friends
that had like uh there's this has been
the year of like cannibalism for some
reason right and like for me years past
there was no cannibalism movies right
and all of a sudden this year there's
like
three different ones four different ones
that are actually mainstream films that
like you know hit whatever these poor
guys are just pulling their hair out
because they're just like ah we thought
we were making something new and
just luck of the draw I guess you know
just so happens but I guess the question
I guess was what was the question it was
uh if how do I tell something's original
sorry oh no how does the filmmaker know
they have something worth telling I mean
because you love the Fable men's but
that's because Steven Spielberg has this
long fascinating story and a track
record yeah but or Sam Mendes he did
Empire of light as sort of an Ode to his
his life as well but these are people
that have already been out there where
there's someone that's just the writer
director producer and it's their first
one and it's about them
how how does someone know that it's
worth telling
look I think that you have a team around
you that in addition to yourself you
should have some experienced people
around you to say yeah listen I haven't
seen that before or yes I can see how
this could be a very Niche thing and we
could probably get into Sundance or we
could get into some place like this and
get you awareness and awareness is key
because even like on this very personal
story you still have to sell it and
actually make money off of it and like
how are they gonna do this there are so
many movies that play at Sundance now
that a don't get sold and B like even if
they even if they did get sold to
somebody at Sundance they scratch their
heads as to how they're going to Market
this film and it comes out in two
theaters and then dies to slow death
someplace you never hear about it again
and that goes back to the idea like how
are we going to Market this film and who
is this movie for right again I think
that the answer to the question is I
think you should surround yourself with
enough people who are experienced people
they can kind of help and guide you to
kind of maybe let you know whether this
is experience this is something that
should be made or not or even like this
is something we have seen or not seen or
do we think it's marketable in some way
to somebody right I think those that's
the answer to the question you should
you should try to get advice and
surround yourself with people the more
the more you can mentors whatever what
have you that can probably kind of maybe
guide
and is that also because maybe there's a
curse with Sundance because these are
all autors these are all people that
love Cinema but whereas what's really
going to sell is Middle America where
maybe people won't want to see these Art
House films or maybe they will I mean
look you know even in the horror
Community we like we had uh our 1br film
debuted at Fantasia which is like
arguably like there's two huge genre
festivals in the world and one of them
is that and the other one's stitches in
Spain and we got pulled aside we didn't
win anything we got pulled aside by one
of the judges and she's like listen you
didn't win anything but I'm gonna tell
you I think you're going to be the most
successful movie out of here this this
you know this particular year because
there is something that's very
mainstream about the film and I think
that people are going to want to see it
and true enough between like ourselves
and this other movie The Wretched and
swallow we were the top probably the top
three films in terms of how we produced
in the actual Marketplace so even though
we weren't the artsiest or most original
in some way we still were able to do
something in an interesting regard
where does your confidence come from
Luke
I think I'm just old I mean I'm I just
turned 50 this year and I think I've
seen a lot of and I think the other
part of it is that I just don't care
anymore like I mean like
I I care and I'm strategic and political
right but at a certain point I'm I'm
with age I've become less fearful right
and once I figured out that like you
know we did one movie and I have
contemporaries and you become friends
with other filmmakers and you see
they're doing it and they did this and
you can do this you get Confidence from
from meeting other filmmakers and and
and having made at least one film to the
point where you don't feel fearful about
you don't have as much fear as you
usually had when you hadn't you had made
a film when you made one at least it's
under your belt you can kind of move on
to other things
um but I hope that answers the question
I get I guess going back to it I think
uh mine is
I I I've
I'm fairly I'm a fairly confident person
but I've been more fearful in life but
now I'm less fearful with age I guess to
say that makes sense what was the fear
about was it that you didn't want to
come out of failure or disappoint
someone sure I mean I think that's I
mean that's that's Universal with anyone
I mean I think that um you know I'm not
saying I'm high high functioning or
something like that oh God I'm a normal
person but I think that like I'm a very
prideful person in certain regards too
and like you know I tested movies for 18
years I'm gonna make a like piece of
crap movie like that that would kill me
that would kill me that like I had done
that on a personal level like you've
been able to help other people with
their films you can't help yourself with
your own film that kind of thing so
there is sort of a sense of Pride and
and you know Pride base of Prior career
let's call it that that's in the mix
um but like look I mean I think the
other part of it is that you know
we all have something holding us back I
mean sometimes we hold ourselves back
like oh this script isn't good enough or
this you know this uh this money is not
enough money right whereas if you just
went out there and jumped in the pool
you'd be much better off you learn how
to swim a lot faster rather than sitting
on the side of the pool and like waiting
for is this the right time I should jump
since I do it now should I did it just
jump in
that's what I would tell you